Travis Kelce has been busy donating
12,000 meals to the Kansas City
community and through his foundation 87
and running also wanted to take care of
an organization near and dear to his
heart in Kansas City operation
breakthrough he donated all the food and
supplies to keep them business as usual
for 15 weeks always great to catch up
with the Kansas City Chiefs all-pro
tight end Travis Kelce what are you
gonna do today aside from this interview
like what what else is the game plan um
I'm probably gonna cook a few meals Dan
and play some video games I think I
think I just entered a ESPN Madden
tournament I believe so so I think
that's so that's what I got going on I'm
video games and just cooking meals and
working out what do you have as far as
workout equipment there um
ironically like during the season I
ended up buying a house first time
homeowner and I went out and I bought
equipment like a rack and a big
treadmill so I've been and I've got just
about a full full on weight weight room
and ability to do just about anything I
need at the house so it's a spring kind
of convenient due to the circumstances
but um definitely not the way I imagined
using it all right let's go around the
room one like a max benchpress for
Travis Kelce one rep polio start with
you I'll go he's long guy but he's
pretty jacked yeah but you don't want
long arms right but he's jacked as well
he's got 375 no problem 375 fritzy 360
360 McLovin he's tall like me much less
275 all right seat no Connor
we got 276 272 I'm gonna go to 77 Travis
Kelce max bench I'm not gonna lie I
haven't got under a bench like an actual
bar I haven't I haven't done actual
bench I work out in probably three years
I've been I've been I've been dumbbells
stability shoulder stuff back in the day
my the most I've ever thrown up was
probably
3:25 3:30 okay
all right we have a winner I mean that's
what I do around 3:15 3:20 oh that's not
funny I don't know why no it's not why I
I'm not laughing
oh that made me smile that made me smile
I would love to see you get under hid
under the bench and start rapping
somehow dan I'm more like Brady I'm more
about flexibility nice yeah nice I think
I'm going that route too I think once
you hit like 30 31 you just you stop
using actual weight and you just use
rubber bands it's all about pliability
there you go
yeah I know it's gonna be strange to see
Brady in that Tampa Bay uniform it
doesn't even feel real it's very similar
to LeBron in Los Angeles
have you ever had a conversation with
Brady you know what I think it was a
quick hey good game as it drives winning
touchdown so I think yeah that was about
the only time I really had a
conversation with him but it seems like
a great guy oh wait that that wasn't the
one in Kansas City where somebody jumped
offsides and you didn't talk after that
okay
no it was actually the game earlier that
year okay okay yeah that one in Kansas
City the playoff game you probably
didn't have anything to say no I didn't
talk to anybody for a while after that
one do you trade jerseys um has to be a
special occasion like when I played my
brother a guy like Zach Ertz or a guy
like George Kittel just uh people that
are that I'm good friends with sometimes
of the guys that I admire
throughout the years like a guy that I
grew up watching Ted Ginn jr. out of
Cleveland Ohio hmm you know just it's
got to be a very unique situation for
sure we wanted to do the how much is
Patrick mahomes going to make per year
over under and then
let you weigh in on this Paulie
over-under mahomes per season 42 and a
half mil 42 and a half fritzy 44 no
mclovin 44 and 3/4 ok seat no counter 45
45 I'm gonna go 39 9 what do you think
mahomes was gonna make per year with
this next contract
I think he's going 50 a year I think
he's going to make 50 million dollars
per year on the field and worth it worth
every penny of it
when's the last time you did something
where you went oh my god
you know what like in terms of like just
on the fee like in her life or like kind
of like oh come on Pat why would you do
that like that either way on the field
was probably in the Super Bowl when he
tried to run it in from about the 15 or
20 yard line gun I thought he was gonna
get blown up bad what are we doing a
quarter we're trying to win this thing
man guys I'll tell you what I've never
never seen any football player more
uncomfortable in the situation of having
to make a one-on-one move on somebody
than Patrick mahomes in space
wait he's it looks like he's got
athleticism no he can move he can move
and he did pull the heavy out against
the Titans on the long touchdown run the
heavy and then the slow spin into the
end zone against the Titans he pulled
that out gotta respect him in that
regard but when he's coming downhill and
he has a guy coming at him downhill man
it's like the awkward confusing should I
make a move should I jump should I slide
and then he tries to kind of slide at
the end and then just get smoked in the
middle of being have you watched this
interval um a few times but what do you
listen what are you watching for
um I would say really just a reminisce
the the feeling that I had on the field
throughout the entire game the
excitement the getting through the
adversity with the teammates those are
things that I feel like I'll cherish for
the rest of my life and and they
certainly aren't going away anytime soon
what did you do with the Lombardi Trophy
uh I picked it up I kissed it and then I
chugged a beer off of it like I won the
Stanley Cup
so you chugged a beer off of it so like
you used as a luge with beer oh the
Lombardi lose which Kelsey had a better
better time after they won the Superbowl
you were your brother
ah man I would say initially I don't I
don't know if yeah I I don't know if
anyone partied the way we partied you
know after Super Bowl I mean we really
got after we had some fun but I think I
think because this whole quarantine
thing and everything just died down real
fast were you shirtless a lot doctor um
no not really
kept my shirt on it was still a little
chilly out still a little chilly out so
I kept the shirt on but uh it was it was
probably soaking wet in an alcohol or I
should say beverages and of course your
brother didn't get cheated no he did not
your parents must have been so proud
[Laughter]
yeah you can't tell mom or dad anything
right now as you're sure when when do
you think you're going to be able to go
back to the facility I think if you give
it about a month and a half I think
we're gonna kind of have to take these
precautions through April through May
and then I don't know we'll see we'll
see what happens happens after that but
um I mean I'm just talking everybody on
the team and the coaches everyone's just
ready to get
after it pretty motivated and OTAs are
probably going to be cancelled right and
these are these are great questions in
great great talks I just I don't I don't
know if they would necessarily just
botch OTAs I think I think they would
want to have some type of mini camp or
at least a week or two or a month
getting together in the offseason yeah I
think everything's in a state of flux
but you surprised they're having the
draft no no I knew they had to go
through with the draft I do see it more
as it's like it's kind of like the MLB
Draft almost I feel like if they don't
do a huge production do they know
they've tried they tried to ramp it up a
little bit on the MLB Network where they
have the draft picks there but it
doesn't have any buzz drive lounge
I know police I know if you don't get
threatened did you get drafted in
baseball no no I did not it was probably
my best sport but I did not I didn't
play enough I only played one year at
high school and you you're a wrestler
too were you no no that was Jason oh he
was the wrestler in middle school and
then he played a it was a winter sport
so he played hockey in high school and I
play basketball oh man I can't imagine
your brother playing hockey yeah he's
pretty much he would he would hurt some
people I want to give another plug to
this so you donated 12,000 meals to the
Kansas City community your foundation 87
and running and you're also taking care
of operation breakthrough donated all
the food and supplies to keep them
business as usual for 15 weeks anything
else you want to add to that no no
there's nothing I mean everyone be safe
everyone take the take the right safety
precautions the safety measures out here
wash your hands and then just uh be
appreciative of the situations you have
in life because obviously it's a not
everyone's as fortunate as we
right now the pride of Cleveland Travis
Kelce Hey good to talk to you be smart
be safe and thanks for joining us always
Dan you do the same take it easy guys
and then Travis Kelce